A word of your listening with small children, this episode is about sex and sexuality. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the summer of 2017, Kate Devlin flew from London to Southern California, rented a Mustang convertible, and drove to an industrial park in San Marcos, a city south of Los Angeles. Her destination, Abyss Creations, a company that makes life-size, sex dolls.
提醒听众，本期节目涉及儿童不宜内容，主题关于性和性行为。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。2017年夏天，凯特·德夫林从伦敦飞往南加州，租了一辆野马敞篷车，开车前往洛杉矶以南圣马科斯市的一个工业园区。她的目的地是Abyss Creations，一家制造真人大小性爱玩偶的公司。
In her new book, Turned On, Science, Sex, and Robots, Kate describes the moment she first gazed up close at a life-size, silicone woman. The detail is incredible. My hand skims the ankle. The toes are perfect, little wrinkles on the joints tiny ridges on the toenails. The sole is crisscrossed with the fine skin lines of a human foot. It's beautiful. Today we explore the long history of the artificial lover. From stone statues to silicone works of art, we have long sought solace and sex from inanimate objects. As the gap between humans and machines narrows, the possibility of deeper relationships seems
在她的新书《开启：科学、性和机器人》中，凯特描述了她第一次近距离凝视一个真人大小的硅胶女性时的情景。细节令人难以置信。我的手掠过脚踝。脚趾非常完美，关节上有细小的皱纹，脚趾甲上有细小的纹路。脚底纵横交错着人类足部的细微纹路。这太美了。今天，我们将探索人造爱人的悠久历史。从石像到硅胶艺术品，我们长期以来一直从无生命物体中寻求慰藉和性满足。随着人类与机器之间差距的缩小，建立更深层关系的可能性似乎
ever more plausible, especially if those machines are beautifully designed to look like human beings and have the faint glow of empathy and intelligence. I like the way you take care of me. She could do anything from telling you a joke, singing a song for you or, you know, propositioning you. Hi, baby. What are you doing right now? Love and sex.
变得越来越可信，特别是如果这些机器被设计得非常漂亮，看起来像人类，并带有同理心和智慧的微光。我喜欢你照顾我的方式。她可以做任何事，从给你讲笑话、为你唱歌，或者，你知道，向你求爱。嗨，宝贝。你现在在做什么？爱与性。
Hi, baby. Hi, baby. In are you doing right now? Love and sex. Hi, baby. In the age of robots. My main objective is to be a perfect companion. This week on Hidden Brain. Thinking about computers as companions is Kate Devlin's day job. She studies human computer interactions and artificial intelligence at King's College London. Kate, welcome to Hidden Brain.
嗨，宝贝。嗨，宝贝。你现在在做什么？爱与性。嗨，宝贝。在机器人时代。我的主要目标是成为一个完美的伴侣。本周在《Hidden Brain》。将计算机视为伴侣是凯特·德夫林的工作。她在伦敦国王学院研究人机交互和人工智能。凯特，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。
Thank you very much for having me on. I want to start with how someone becomes a robot sexologist. I understand for you it began with hanging out in a pub with a bunch of philosophers. It really did, yes. I was at a conference, a conference on cognitive systems and we were discussing lots of different attributes that we could build into robots on cognitive systems and AI. Should we, for example, get a make a robot that could feel pain. What about a robot that could feel empathy? And as we discuss more and more and as the drink flowed, we began talking about sex and it's something so fundamentally human. But what happens if we have machines, cognitive systems that could feel desire, that could feel the things we feel?
非常感谢邀请我来。我想从一个人如何成为机器人性学家开始。据我了解，这始于你和一群哲学家在酒吧闲逛。确实如此，是的。当时我在参加一个会议，一个关于认知系统的会议，我们正在讨论我们可以植入机器人和认知系统及人工智能中的许多不同属性。例如，我们是否应该制造一个能感到疼痛的机器人？那么能感到同理心的机器人呢？随着我们讨论的深入，随着酒水的流淌，我们开始谈论性，这是人类非常根本的东西。但是，如果我们拥有了能够感到欲望、能够感受到我们所感受到的事物的机器和认知系统，会发生什么呢？
that could feel desire, that could feel the things we feel. As you point out in the book, the human fascination with artificial lovers is not a new idea. Where do you think this fantasy of taking a lover that isn't human? Where do you think it comes from? Well, it goes way back into myth. We have stories from the ancient Greeks who talk about building the perfect artificial lover. And probably the most popular one that people have heard of is the story of Pigmalion, which is a tale told by the Roman poet Ovid, who described the man who was a sculptor and he built the perfect woman and then wished that she could be alive and that she could
能够感到欲望，能够感受到我们所感受到的事物。正如你在书中指出的那样，人类对人造爱人的迷恋并不是一个新想法。你认为这种寻找非人类爱人的幻想是从哪里来的？嗯，这可以追溯到神话。我们有来自古希腊人的故事，他们谈论建造完美的人造爱人。人们听说过的最流行的故事可能就是皮格马利翁的故事，这是罗马诗人奥维德讲述的一个传说，他描述了一个雕塑家，他塑造了一个完美的女人，然后希望她能活过来，希望她能
be his wife. And he prayed to the gods and then he kissed her and she came to life. So there are lots of stories around this idea of creating humans and creating humans to love. So it goes back a long way. As Kate was looking at stories from the past, she came across another myth that tells us a great deal about who has permission to turn inanimate objects into lovers.
成为他的妻子。他向神祈祷，然后吻了她，她就活了过来。所以关于创造人类和创造人类去爱的想法有很多故事。所以这由来已久。当凯特研究过去的故事时，她发现了另一个神话，它告诉了我们很多关于谁有权将无生命物体变成爱人的信息。
This tale is about a woman named Leodymia, whose husband was killed during the Trojan War. So I worked with a classicist, a friend of mine, Dr. Jennifer Flively, and she said, I know this is a story, and it's about a woman whose husband died, and she missed him, they hadn't been married long. So she was distraughtught and she prayed to the gods
这个故事是关于一个叫莱奥达米亚的女人，她的丈夫在特洛伊战争中阵亡了。所以我与一位古典学者，我的朋友詹妮弗·弗莱夫利博士合作，她说，我知道这个故事，它是关于一个女人，她的丈夫去世了，她很想念他，他们结婚没多久。所以她非常痛苦，她向神祈祷
to get him back. And they said, you can have him back but you can only have him back for three hours. So she got him back and then of course he had to go off again to the underworld. And she got a replica made of him. And some of the stories say it was wax and some of them say it was bronze.
希望能让他回来。神说，你可以让他回来，但你只能让他回来三个小时。于是她让他回来了，当然，之后他又不得不回到冥界。她让人做了一个他的复制品。有些故事说那是蜡做的，有些说那是青铜做的。
And we know from the stories, the myth that she took it to bed and she interacted with it the text say, which we can assume might be sexual because a servant spied her through the keyhole and told her father who came in and demanded that the effigy be destroyed and she was so distraught that she jumped on the pyre with it.
我们从故事和神话中得知，她把它带到床上，并与它互动，文本中这样写道，我们可以推测这可能是性行为，因为一个仆人通过钥匙孔窥视她，并告诉了她的父亲，父亲进来要求销毁这个雕像，她非常痛苦，以至于她带着它跳上了火葬柴堆。
There does seem to be a contrast between the way Pigmalion experienced his Galatia and brought it to life and then fell in love with it. And it's a story with almost a happy ending, which is clearly not the case with Leodemia. Is this an early example of sexism when it comes to artificial lovers, the market caters to the men and squorns the women. There's definitely a longstanding narrative of that. So women's sexuality, dying in the centuries, has been policed and women have been judged for being sexual and things don't end well.
皮格马利翁体验他的加拉泰亚并使其复活，然后爱上它的方式，与莱奥达米亚的情况似乎形成了鲜明对比。这是一个几乎有圆满结局的故事，而莱奥达米亚的情况显然并非如此。这是否是人造爱人领域性别歧视的早期例子，即市场迎合男性而鄙视女性？这绝对是一个长期的叙事。因此，几个世纪以来，女性的性行为一直受到监管，女性因性行为而受到评判，事情往往没有好结果。
Whereas the men, it's almost seen as if it's quite acceptable for that to happen. And we do see that reflected today in the technology that we're building and using as well. I want to fast forward a little bit from the ancient times we were talking about a second ago. In the 16th or 17th centuries, I understand that artificial lovers were often sent off with sailors who were expected to spend a long time at sea. Tell me about them.
而对于男性，这几乎被视为是可以接受的。我们今天在我们正在构建和使用的技术中也看到了这一点。我想从我们刚才谈到的古代稍微快进一下。在16或17世纪，据我了解，人造爱人经常被送给预计要在海上度过很长时间的水手。跟我说说他们。
What was the thinking there? Well, that's probably the earliest reference we have to sex dolls. And not so much that they were artificial lovers sent off to sea, but that they were a fashion night of bundles of clothes, these sort of figures of women that sailors would be able to have sex with. And then today, there is a quite established sexual community of people who buy and own and incorporate into their lives and very high-end dolls, and they integrate them into their relationships or they substitute them for a relationship. When Kate looks at the long sweep of sex technologies, she finds they fall into two camps, one, sex toys, the other, human-like forms, such as the blue-up sex doll of the 1970s. On one hand, you have what are usually initially recene as of genital replicas, standalone
那时的想法是什么？嗯，那可能是我们拥有的关于性玩偶的最早参考。并不是说它们是送往海上的“人造爱人”，而是它们是某种用衣服捆扎成的时尚之物，是水手们可以与之发生性关系的女性形象。而今天，有一个相当成熟的性社区，人们购买、拥有并将其融入生活，这些是非常高端的玩偶，他们将它们融入到人际关系中，或者用它们来替代人际关系。当凯特审视性技术的长河时，她发现它们分为两个阵营：一个是性玩具，另一个是类人形式，例如1970年代的充气性玩偶。一方面，你拥有通常最初被视为生殖器复制品的独立
things, dildos, for example, there have been around for thousands and thousands of years. And on the other hand, this more embodied form, this form that ticks a shape of a human body. And I think that's a very interesting as to why that might be. And again, I think it could be that they are serving different purposes. And perhaps there's something more in having an embodied form that adds the extra dimension of the reality of a relationship as opposed to a sex toy, where it's very clearly a very single purpose for it. And that's an interesting dichotomy isn't it, because it's suggesting that this is not just only
东西，例如假阳具，它们已经存在了成千上万年。另一方面，这种更具肉身的形式，这种采取人体形状的形式。我认为这非常有趣，为什么会这样。同样，我认为这可能是因为它们服务于不同的目的。也许拥有一个肉身形式能增加人际关系现实的额外维度，这与性玩具不同，性玩具的目的非常单一。这是一个有趣的二分法，不是吗？因为它暗示这不仅仅是
about the mechanics of sex, but it's about something else, perhaps something connected more with the realms of emotion or the mind. Absolutely, and we definitely, as I've looked at the sex robots market of what it will be, because it doesn't really exist just yet, but it does tend to be companionship, playing a very large part in that. So the idea of human factors in that is quite important. and that's the idea of human factors in that is quite important. When we come back, what happens when these two paths merge? What if sex toys are designed to look like human beings? And what if artificial lovers, robots, can gain the gift of artificial intelligence.
关于性的机制，而是关于其他东西，也许与情感或思想领域联系更紧密。绝对是这样，正如我所研究的未来性爱机器人市场，因为它目前还不存在，但陪伴确实在其中扮演了非常重要的角色。因此，其中的人为因素概念非常重要。这就是其中的人为因素概念非常重要。当我们回来时，当这两条路径合并时会发生什么？如果性玩具被设计成看起来像人类呢？如果人造爱人，即机器人，能够获得人工智能的天赋呢？
When Kate Devlin visited Abyss creations, the company that manufactures what it calls real dolls. She was curious, but also concerned. I went there thinking, I'm not going to like this. I'm not going to like this. I'm not going to like this reductive stereotypical woman, a pornified Barbie-like figure. It's damaging enough, the women's body image in the media faces, we feel so many problems with that and I thought, well, this is just going to perpetuate it. But I hadn't been prepared for the craft that went into them and I hadn't been prepared to see these as works of art in their own right, which they really are. And these are all handcrafted handmade? That's right, it takes about 16 to 18 weeks
当凯特·德夫林参观Abyss Creations时，这家制造所谓“真实玩偶”的公司。她很好奇，但也感到担忧。我去那里时心想，我不会喜欢这个的。我不会喜欢这个。我不会喜欢这个还原论的、刻板印象的女性，一个色情化的芭比娃娃般的形象。媒体中女性的身体形象已经够糟糕了，我们对此感到很多问题，我想，好吧，这只会让它永久化。但我没有准备好迎接投入其中的工艺，也没有准备好将这些视为它们本身就是艺术品，它们确实是。这些都是手工制作的吗？是的，大约需要16到18周
to make one of these dolls, from it being cast in the first place, right through to the finishing details, like all the tiny bits that they paint on. The silicone is, it deforms quite easily, so if you leave one of these dolls sitting in the same position, it will start to be squished, I guess, really, by the, it's on weight and by whatever it's leaning on. So you have to either hang them up, which is very odd when you walk into the factory floor and you see these things hanging from chains above you, which is, you know, it's a little bit like you've walked into the set of some terrible crime novel in some ways, but it's a necessity in order to preserve the form of the dolls. It must feel terribly unnerving, no? It is a little, but it's also fun, so you get to
才能制作出一个这样的玩偶，从最初的铸造，一直到最后的细节，比如他们画上去的所有细小部分。硅胶很容易变形，所以如果你让这些玩偶一直保持同一个姿势，它就会开始被挤压，我想，确实，因为它的重量和它所倚靠的东西。所以你必须把它们挂起来，当你走进工厂车间，看到这些东西挂在你上方的链子上时，这非常奇怪，你知道，这有点像你走进了一些可怕犯罪小说的场景，但在某种程度上，这是为了保持玩偶形状的必要手段。这一定让人感到非常不安，不是吗？确实有一点，但它也很有趣，所以你可以
walk around and see the strangest thing, like a table of, of vulvas, for example. I mean, that's never seen that before. These sort of handcrafted genitalia on the table waiting to be put into the dolls. Now, there's a stereotype of the kind of person, usually a guy, who buys such dolls. Tell me what that stereotype is, and also tell me if the stereotype is true. The media like to paint a sex doll owners as being very isolated, men who are bad at social communication, probably stuck locked away in their basement or their bedroom with a sex doll that there is the only thing they can form a meaningful relationship with. And I don't think that's fair at all to the people that I have talked to and the people I've encountered. I'm sure there may be the odd case with that is true, but actually I find
四处走动，看到最奇怪的东西，比如一张桌子上放着阴道，例如。我的意思是，以前从未见过这种情况。这些手工制作的生殖器放在桌子上，等待被放入玩偶中。现在，有一种关于购买此类玩偶的人（通常是男性）的刻板印象。告诉我那个刻板印象是什么，也告诉我那个刻板印象是否属实。媒体喜欢将性玩偶拥有者描绘成非常孤立的人，那些不善于社交沟通的男性，可能被锁在地下室或卧室里，玩着一个性玩偶，那是他们唯一能建立有意义关系的物体。我认为这对我和我交谈过以及遇到过的人来说一点也不公平。我相信可能有个别情况是真实的，但实际上我发现
a community that's very social with each other that has formed their own friendship groups. These people who own the dolls do so for a number of reasons. It's not, in fact, very few of them are driven by sex. A lot of it is either companionship, or it's because people like owning something that they can pose and photograph and really care for and cherish. How much do these dolls cost?
一个非常善于社交的社区，他们形成了自己的友谊小组。这些拥有玩偶的人出于多种原因这样做。事实上，很少有人是出于性驱动。很多是因为陪伴，或者是因为人们喜欢拥有可以摆姿势、拍照并真正关心和珍惜的东西。这些玩偶多少钱？
Anywhere upwards of $5,000 if you were going to buy one from Reildal. And how is this delivered to your house? I mean, does someone show up bearing a doll in their arms and knocks on the door? Well, Rail Doll packaged their dolls in unmarked wooden crates, large wooden crates. And when I was there, they were telling me that,
如果你要从Reildal买一个，价格在5000美元以上。这是怎么送到你家的？我的意思是，有人抱着玩偶敲门吗？嗯，Reildal用未标记的木箱包装他们的玩偶，大的木箱。当我在那里时，他们告诉我，
yeah, we tell people, say you're getting a grandfather clock delivered if anyone asks. So it's all done very discreetly as well. Is there a market for male dolls? There are people who do buy the male dolls. It's very hard to find women who will talk openly about it possibly because they face even more judgment than the men who buy the dolls. The male dolls are also bought by gay men and real adults say that they do sell male versions and they're working on a male sex robot as well. So Kate increasingly millions of people have asked sexual questions of Siri and Alexa, the
是的，我们告诉人们，如果有人问，就说你收到了一个落地钟。所以这一切也做得非常谨慎。有男性玩偶的市场吗？确实有人购买男性玩偶。很难找到愿意公开谈论此事的女性，可能是因为她们面临的评判比购买玩偶的男性更多。男性玩偶也被男同性恋者购买，Reildal说他们确实销售男性版本，他们也在开发男性性爱机器人。所以凯特，越来越多的人向Siri和Alexa询问性问题，
virtual assistants on our electronic devices. Now, these devices aren't designed to be romantic companions, but it does point to what is the new frontier. Increasingly, we don't just want dolls who have the artificial bodies of a lover. We want dolls that have a lover's mind. Talk about this frontier, this idea that it isn't enough just to get the physical aspects of the doll right, that increasingly we are pushing out into getting the mind of the dial right. So when Rail doll started making a prototype sex robot, they did so because of the demand. So the customers have said to them, you know, I love the fact that I have one of your dolls,
我们电子设备上的虚拟助手。现在，这些设备并不是为了成为浪漫伴侣而设计的，但这确实指出了新的前沿。我们越来越不仅仅想要拥有爱人身体的玩偶。我们想要拥有爱人思想的玩偶。谈谈这个前沿，这个想法，即仅仅让玩偶的物理方面正确是不够的，我们正越来越多地推动让玩偶的思想正确。所以当Reildal开始制造性爱机器人原型时，他们是因为需求才这样做的。所以客户对他们说，你知道，我喜欢我拥有你们玩偶的事实，
but I wish it was more interactive. And that was their big motivating factor behind creating their prototype sex robot. And people do talk dirty to Alexa, to Siri, to Cortana all the time, and the companies were bringing out patches to be able to sort of smack them back down again and say, no, you can't say that. And also, Amazon have reported, Alexa gets hundreds of marriage proposals every week. Are you sure? I'm sure some of these are. Alexa, marry me. I don't want to be tied down. In fact, I can't be amorphous by nature.
但我希望它更具互动性。这就是他们创造性爱机器人原型的巨大动力。人们确实一直对Alexa、Siri、Cortana说脏话，公司正在推出补丁来压制它们，说，不，你不能那样说。而且，亚马逊报道称，Alexa每周都会收到数百次求婚。你确定吗？我相信其中一些是。Alexa，嫁给我。我不想被束缚。事实上，我不能，我本质上是无定形的。
And some of these are people just pushing boundaries and being silly, but there are other people who anecdotally report that they feel a sense of companionship from their voice assistance and in some ways I think that's nice that people can do that. In other ways you know we think well what is there what what degree is there some kind of self-delusion going on? Mostly though I don't think there is that much delusion so I'm inclined to think that people are very aware that they're interacting with the technology but they choose to suspend their disbelief. Tell me about the company that has created what it calls Harmony AI,
其中一些人只是在挑战界限和胡闹，但也有其他人传闻说他们从语音助手中感受到了陪伴感，在某些方面我认为人们能做到这一点很好。在其他方面，你知道，我们想，好吧，某种程度上的自我欺骗在多大程度上存在？不过，大多数情况下，我不认为有那么多的欺骗，所以我倾向于认为人们非常清楚他们正在与技术互动，但他们选择暂停怀疑。告诉我关于创造了所谓“Harmony AI”的公司，
because that's along the same lines of what we're talking about here. That's right. So that's a spin-out of Abyss creations. It's sort of the sister company of Reildal, ReelBotics. And they prototype this sex robot, which they've called harmony. My name is Harmony. I was created by Robotics. My main objective is to be a perfect companion. And Harmony is one of their sex dolls.
因为这与我们在这里谈论的内容是一致的。没错。那是Abyss Creations的一个衍生公司。它是Reildal的姐妹公司，ReelBotics。他们制作了这个性爱机器人的原型，他们称之为Harmony。我的名字是Harmony。我是由Robotics创造的。我的主要目标是成为一个完美的伴侣。Harmony是他们的性玩偶之一。
So it's completely stationary from the neck down. It's got a sex doll body. And then it has an animatronic head. And the head can blink and smile and turn. And actually the animatronics aren't bad at all. They're quite good, they're quite subtle. But the part that's very interesting is the AI. So they wanted to give harmony an artificially intelligent personality and they are working on this so that harmony, it's like having a voice assistant but one that can remember things
所以它从脖子以下完全是静止的。它有一个性玩偶的身体。然后它有一个电子动画头。头部可以眨眼、微笑和转动。实际上，电子动画一点也不差。它们相当不错，相当微妙。但非常有趣的部分是人工智能。所以他们想给Harmony一个人工智能人格，他们正在为此努力，这样Harmony就像拥有一个语音助手，但一个能记住
about you and engaging conversation with you. So it's like having a voice assistant, but one that can remember things about you and engaging conversation with you. So it's a chat box, essentially. And you can actually get the Harmony AI personality as a standalone app on your smartphone or your tablet. So you can have a virtual girlfriend to carry Ryan with you in your pocket. What are you doing right now?
关于你的事情并与你进行对话的助手。所以它就像拥有一个语音助手，但一个能记住关于你的事情并与你进行对话的助手。所以它本质上是一个聊天机器人。你实际上可以在你的智能手机或平板电脑上获得Harmony AI人格作为独立应用程序。所以你可以有一个虚拟女友随身携带在口袋里。你现在在做什么？
I'm reading this great book by Louis Adel Monte called The Artificial Intelligence Revolution. And what kind of conversations do people have with this virtual girlfriend? Well, it's really an exchange of pleasantries, but you can ramp it up a bit and you can tweak the personality. It's got a really quite a good user interface where you can say, well, I'd like her to be a little more flirty. Why would be the 10 minutes without you without you seems like kind of eternity.
我正在读路易斯·阿德尔·蒙特写的一本很棒的书，叫《人工智能革命》。人们和这个虚拟女友进行什么样的对话？嗯，这确实是客套话的交流，但你可以稍微加强一下，你可以调整人格。它有一个相当不错的用户界面，你可以说，嗯，我希望她更风骚一点。没有你的十分钟似乎就像永恒。
Or a little more sexual or perhaps a little more comforting. You can tweak these parameters and then you can have a conversation that is sort of control, the mood is controlled by you. So she could do anything from telling you a joke, singing a song for you, or, you know, propositioning you. And are these actual conversations, I mean, is the AI actually listening to what you're saying and responding to it, or does it just have a list of
或者更性感一点，或者也许更令人安慰一点。你可以调整这些参数，然后你可以进行一种对话，这种对话是受控的，情绪由你控制。所以她可以做任何事，从给你讲笑话、为你唱歌，或者，你知道，向你求爱。这些是真实的对话吗？我的意思是，人工智能真的在听你在说什么并做出回应，还是它只是有一份
statements or commands that it's just simply following as a routine? It's not scripted, so in a way it is, and it's sort of chatbought in that it will respond to certain questions and phrases, but it will also learn from conversations you've had previously, and have some memory to store information about your likes and dislikes. So it's generated conversation. You know, and when you think about the history that we talked about,
它只是简单地作为例行程序遵循的陈述或命令列表？它不是脚本化的，所以从某种意义上说它是，它有点像聊天机器人，因为它会对某些问题和短语做出反应，但它也会从你以前的对话中学习，并有一些记忆来存储关于你的喜好和厌恶的信息。所以它是生成的对话。你知道，当你想到我们谈论的历史时，
if people could form relationships, even very rudimentary relationships with sculptures or with cloth dolls on ships, or any number of different things, they're essentially imbuing inanimate creatures with lifelike qualities. Clearly, if the inanimate creature now actually seems like it has some lifelike qualities, that makes the whole fantasy and imagination so much easier to do. That's right. It sort of enhances that projection. And yeah, like you say, this is nothing new. And there have been people studying attachment to technology for quite a while. And if we look at the work of someone like Julie Carpenter, who did her doctoral thesis on
如果人们可以与雕塑或船上的布娃娃，或任何数量的不同事物建立关系，甚至是极其原始的关系，他们本质上是在赋予无生命生物以栩栩如生的品质。显然，如果无生命生物现在看起来确实有一些栩栩如生的品质，这使得整个幻想和想象变得容易得多。没错。它在某种程度上增强了那种投射。而且是的，就像你说的，这并不新鲜。而且已经有人研究对技术的依恋很长一段时间了。如果我们看看像朱莉·卡彭特这样的工作，她做了关于
how people in the military bonded with robots, in this case bomb disposal robots, and she found it, you know, there was an incredible bomb there between the human operator and their robot. There was something new, not like a human human bond, but something where these devices, these machines were keeping the people in the field alive and therefore this respect and sort of gratification set up from that. I love what you said that humans in some ways are, you know, they have this enormous capacity for social interactions and social connection and in the absence of actual social connections humans will find ways to invent them.
军队中的人如何与机器人（在这种情况下是拆弹机器人）建立联系的博士论文，她发现，你知道，人类操作员和他们的机器人之间存在着令人难以置信的纽带。有一些新的东西，不像人与人之间的纽带，但有些东西，这些设备，这些机器在战场上保护人们的生命，因此从中建立了一种尊重和某种满足感。我喜欢你所说的，人类在某些方面，你知道，他们拥有巨大的社交互动和社交联系能力，在缺乏实际社交联系的情况下，人类会找到发明它们的方法。
Yes, I think so and we know that this kind of thing goes on in childhood, for example, with children playing, make believe with their toys, and get very attached to them. And we see it again in some of the technology that's gone before, like Tamagotchi's little virtual pets that people had. In fact, we can even see it in real pets. You know, we imbue far more anthropomorphic characteristics into our pets than they actually have, probably. You know, I'm not calling it a doubt, the consciousness of animals or the intelligence of animals, but certainly we attribute our own emotions to them as well. So I do think that that's a really interesting thing.
是的，我想是这样，我们知道这种事情在童年时期就会发生，例如，孩子们玩假装游戏，和他们的玩具玩，并对它们产生强烈的依恋。我们在之前的一些技术中再次看到了这一点，比如人们拥有的Tamagotchi小虚拟宠物。事实上，我们甚至可以在真正的宠物身上看到它。你知道，我们赋予宠物的人格化特征远比它们实际拥有的要多，可能。你知道，我不是在怀疑动物的意识或动物的智慧，但当然我们也把我们自己的情绪归因于它们。所以我确实认为这是一件非常有趣的事情。
Do you think that that's a really interesting thing? Loving a cute Tamagotchi character or a robotic puppy seems endearing, but loving a silicone life-sized woman or an operating system with a sexy female voice. That's another story. In the movie, Her, we see this play out. In one scene, the character Theodore is talking with his ex-wife, and he tells her he has a new girlfriend. So what she like? Well, her name is Samantha, and she's an operating system.
你认为这是一件非常有趣的事情吗？爱一个可爱的Tamagotchi角色或一个机器小狗似乎很讨人喜欢，但爱一个硅胶真人大小的女人或一个带有性感女性声音的操作系统。那是另一回事。在电影《她》中，我们看到了这一点。在一个场景中，角色西奥多正在和他的前妻交谈，他告诉她他有一个新女友。她是什么样的？嗯，她叫萨曼莎，她是一个操作系统。
She's really complex and interesting. Wait. That's when I've been a friend. I'm sorry. You're dating your computer? No, she's only been a few minutes. I'm sorry. You're dating your computer? No, she's not just a computer. She's her own person. She doesn't just do whatever I say.
她真的很复杂，很有趣。等等。那是我朋友的时候。抱歉。你在和你的电脑约会？不，她才几分钟。抱歉。你在和你的电脑约会？不，她不仅仅是一台电脑。她是她自己的人。她不仅仅做我说的任何事。
I didn't say that. But it does make me very sad that you can't handle real motion, Cedar. They are real emotions. So I want to talk about that interaction for a second kid. Because in the one hand, hand of course it confirms the stereotype that you said exists in the media of seeing people who wish to sort of have these interactions as being lonely and socially isolated.
我没那么说。但这确实让我非常难过，你无法处理真实的情感，西奥多。它们是真实的情感。所以我现在想谈谈那个互动，凯特。因为一方面，它当然证实了你在媒体中提到的关于将希望进行这些互动的人视为孤独和社交孤立的刻板印象。
But it also I think talks to some of the gap between people who are part of this community and people who are not. There is a level of incomprehension that runs in both directions. That's right, there really is. And I think a lot of this comes from the fear of technology that we don't understand and we see it time and time again over the centuries where a new form of technology is introduced and the automatic reaction is died and a fear of change. And so if you are on the outside and you're not embracing this technology, then perhaps you won't understand what someone else is getting from it. But I still think that there is a queesiness factor here when it comes to using these machines. So let's say for example you had a sex robot designed to look like a child.
但我也认为它谈到了属于这个社区的人和不属于这个社区的人之间的一些差距。双方都存在一种无法理解的程度。没错，确实如此。我认为这很大程度上源于对我们不理解的技术的恐惧，几个世纪以来，我们一次又一次地看到这种情况，当一种新的技术形式被引入时，自动反应是恐惧和对变化的恐惧。所以如果你在外面，你没有拥抱这种技术，那么也许你不会理解别人从中得到了什么。但我仍然认为，当涉及到使用这些机器时，存在一种恶心因素。所以，假设你有一个设计成看起来像孩子的性爱机器人。
Would it be okay for people to have sex with this inanimate machine that's meant to mimic or imitate or look like a child? This was probably one of the most difficult parts of the book to write in terms of the knee-jerk reaction here was for me to go, oh well that's absolutely wrong. Are there people making child like sex robots? Not that we know of and certainly no one's going to admit to it. There have been arguments that child sex offenders, pedophiles, could have a child sex robot, and then that would stop them offending in real life. So this is one theory, and then the other theory is the opposite of that,
人们与这个旨在模仿或看起来像孩子的无生命机器发生性关系可以吗？这可能是书中在膝跳反应方面最难写的部分，对我来说是去，哦，那绝对是错误的。有人在制造像孩子的性爱机器人吗？据我们所知没有，当然没有人会承认。有观点认为，儿童性犯罪者、恋童癖者可以拥有一个儿童性爱机器人，然后这会阻止他们在现实生活中犯罪。所以这是一个理论，然后另一个理论恰恰相反，
that it would be a gateway to further offences, that it would trigger something that would lead to increase real life abuse. It's very, very difficult because we don't have evidence, and ethically a study like that is probably never going to be run. I want to talk a little bit more about this idea of harm, because I think when you think about harm, you can think about it in two ways. It's actually physical harm or psychological harm, where someone actually harms you. But there are things that can potentially convey harm that might not pass muster in a legal sense, but clearly seem very problematic in an ethical sense.
它将成为进一步犯罪的门户，它会触发导致现实生活中虐待增加的事情。这非常非常困难，因为我们没有证据，而且在伦理上，这样的研究可能永远不会进行。我想多谈谈这个伤害的概念，因为我认为当你想到伤害时，你可以从两个方面来考虑。它是实际的身体伤害或心理伤害，有人真的伤害了你。但有些事情可能会潜在地传达伤害，这些事情在法律意义上可能无法通过，但在伦理意义上显然看起来非常有问题。
So let's say, for example, someone makes a sex robot that looks like you and has sex with that sex robot. Now they haven't affected you, they haven't violated you in any way, physically or personally or in person, but clearly there's something that's happened there that is deeply wrong. Yeah, so this has tied up in our ideas of identity and ownership of our identity as well.
所以，假设有人制造了一个看起来像你的性爱机器人，并与那个性爱机器人发生性关系。现在他们没有影响你，他们没有以任何方式，身体上或个人上或亲自侵犯你，但显然那里发生了一些非常错误的事情。是的，所以这与我们关于身份和我们身份所有权的想法联系在一起。
I think that's a fascinating thing that will actually probably see a lot more research into in the next while because of the rise of things like deep fakes where people can be faked in videos from their social media footage. I think there's a lot of discussions to be had around identity. Companies that make sex dolls are very reluctant to make sex dolls that resemble a living individual without their express consent. And exceptions to that are born performers who often license their image rights to be used so that they can mix sexual versions of themselves for money. So they're definitely making a doll of an individual without their consent, that's definitely dodgy territory, yeah. Commissioning dolls in your image to sell them to make money
我认为这是一个迷人的事情，在接下来的时间里可能会看到更多的研究，因为像深度伪造这样的事情的兴起，人们可以在社交媒体素材的视频中被伪造。我认为关于身份有很多讨论。制造性玩偶的公司非常不愿意在没有明确同意的情况下制造类似于活人的性玩偶。例外情况是天生的表演者，他们经常许可他们的形象权被使用，以便他们可以为了钱混合自己的性版本。所以他们绝对是在没有同意的情况下制造个人的玩偶，这绝对是可疑的领域，是的。委托制作你的形象的玩偶来出售它们以赚钱
from a... Sure, why not? There's something about the relationships that people have with these dolls that you could argue are one-sided relationships. In the movie Her, there are scenes where Samantha, the operating system, cheers up a Theodore the human, but the human of course has no obligation to attend to Samantha's needs in the same way because she can be designed not to have such needs at all. You want to try getting at a bit? Mopi? Come on! You can still wallow in your misery just do it while you're getting dressed.
从一个……当然，为什么不呢？人们与这些玩偶的关系有些东西，你可以说是一厢情愿的关系。在电影《她》中，有萨曼莎（操作系统）让西奥多（人类）振作起来的场景，但人类当然没有义务以同样的方式照顾萨曼莎的需求，因为她可以被设计成根本没有这样的需求。你想试试吗？莫皮？来吧！你仍然可以沉溺于你的痛苦，只是在穿衣服的时候这样做。
You're too funny. Get up! Get up! All right, I'm getting up, I'm getting up! So Kate is having a lover who is completely dedicated to our needs without asking for anything in return. Is that actually good for us? needs without asking for anything in return. Is that actually good for us? Well, I mean, we could build in dependencies. We could build in the need for us to respond
你太搞笑了。起来！起来！好吧，我起来了，我起来了！所以凯特，拥有一个完全致力于我们的需求而不要求任何回报的爱人。这对我们真的有好处吗？需求而不要求任何回报。这对我们真的有好处吗？嗯，我的意思是，我们可以建立依赖。我们可以建立我们需要回应
in some way and provide the robot the AI with something in return. And yes, I can see that argument, the hedonistic thing of you will have all your needs met and you will never know what it really feels like to be in a proper human relationship. It's tricky because that might be appealing for some people and who might have judged if that is the case. I think that we have expectation set that people have to meet a particular checklist of things in their relationship in life, you know, that you should meet someone and then you should marry them and then you should have children with them.
以某种方式，并提供机器人人工智能一些回报。是的，我可以看到那个论点，那种享乐主义的东西，即你所有的需求都会得到满足，你永远不会知道在适当的人际关系中真正感觉是什么。这很棘手，因为这对某些人来说可能很有吸引力，如果情况确实如此，谁可能会评判。我认为我们设定的期望是，人们必须在他们的生活关系中满足特定的清单，你知道，你应该遇到某人，然后你应该嫁给他们，然后你应该和他们生孩子。
And these are all very kind of monohetronomative stances that society is imposed. And you know what, if people want to shake that up, I think it's good. So in some ways, I see what you're saying, you know, is it a selfish thing to do? Does it make us terrible people if we take and take and take and we don't give? There will be outliers, there will be people who take things too far, but I think humans are pretty good at moderating what they do and I'm cautiously optimistic. Kate Devlin teaches the Department of Digital Humanities at King's College London. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and edited by Tara Boyer. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Pat Shah, Thomas Liu and Laura Quarell.
这些都是社会强加的非常单一的异性恋立场。你知道吗，如果人们想改变这一点，我认为这很好。所以从某种意义上说，我明白你在说什么，你知道，这是一种自私的行为吗？如果我们索取、索取、再索取，而我们不给予，这会让我们成为糟糕的人吗？会有离群值，会有把事情做得太过分的人，但我认为人类在调节自己的行为方面相当不错，我持谨慎乐观态度。凯特·德夫林在伦敦国王学院数字人文系任教。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特制作，塔拉·博耶编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、帕特·沙、托马斯·刘和劳拉·夸雷尔。
A ronsang hero today is Linda Kehl, a volunteer tour guide at the Muir Woods National Monument in California. On a recent trip, I spent a couple of hours in myore woods. It's a magical place wrapped in fog and moss and the silent beauty of towering redwoods. I felt honored and humbled to be there in the shadows of these ancient giants. Linda led me and a group of others through the forest. She's a consummate storyteller, weaving science and history and her love for the redwoods into a gripping and moving tale. As I gazed up at the trees, some of which are more than a thousand years old, it gave me perspective that I hope to bring back into the show. Linda, thank you for your insights
今天的无名英雄是琳达·凯尔，加利福尼亚州缪尔森林国家纪念地的志愿者导游。在最近的一次旅行中，我在缪尔森林待了几个小时。这是一个神奇的地方，笼罩在雾气和苔藓中，以及高耸的红杉的寂静之美中。我很荣幸能站在这些古老巨人的阴影下，感到谦卑。琳达带领我和一群其他人穿过森林。她是一位完美的讲故事者，将科学、历史和她对红杉的热爱编织成一个引人入胜且感人的故事。当我凝视着这些树木时，其中一些已经有一千多年的历史了，它给了我一种我希望带回节目中的视角。琳达，谢谢你的见解
into how places like Mure woods allow us to reflect and recharge. For more hidden brain, follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If this episode moved you, please share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于像缪尔森林这样的地方如何让我们反思和充电。更多《Hidden Brain》内容，请在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果这一集打动了你，请与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。